some Republicans are starting to think
that they're not running against the 80
year old ice cream eating man in the
white house but rather his overly
excited second in command
a vote for President Biden is actually a
vote for president Harris we are running
against Kamala Harris make no bones
about it the New York Times knows it
every liberal knows it they know that
it's Kamala Harris that's going to end
up being president of the United States
if Joe Biden wins this election
Nikki Haley is the only one who thinks
Kamala is important the White House
trying to bolster Harris's image by
putting her in places that make her seem
important The Washington Post noting
that Kamala was quote symbolically
positioned between Kevin McCarthy and
Joe Biden during the debt ceiling talks
but the White House's dismissing
concerns that Kamala will be needed in
the future
what do you say to anyone who is
questioning whether the president would
survive a full four-year term if you
look at what he's been able to do he has
been able to push forward and get done
historic pieces of legislation
he has gotten more done than any other
president this is a president that's
been attacked during 2020 where people
said Oh No One's Gonna he's not gonna
win he's not able to get it done there's
no way he's going to be the next
president and he made it happen all
right so Dana I think they're jumping
the gun here they're talking about
whether
uh Joe Will Survive the the four years
if he's elected the primaries a year
away what are the odds that Joe is
favored to be at the primary he's
degrading faster than a paper straw and
a can of Fresca oh I hate when that
happens I know I hate when that happens
so uh by my count this is the 17th story
that the Washington Post has run about a
remake of Kamala Harris that was planted
by her team to try to show that she was
in that she was instrumental in doing
something and the Washington Post wrote
it right and they said he used to a
symbolically placed and then you can see
oh there she was in between did you hear
anything about her at all at any time at
even when it goes to the Senate where
she has all the relationships there just
wasn't there wasn't any of that I think
that they're starting to realize that
the Republicans will campaign on this
point and say that if you Joe Biden is
elected every single day of the next
four years could be kamala's
inauguration day and they're making it
an issue and today Kamala Harris was
asked do you think that President Biden
will be able to fulfill a full term and
she's they're not sure how to answer it
now I think that barring any unforeseen
circumstances I think the Democrats are
stuck with Joe Biden and he's going to
be their nominee and they are going to
have to figure out whether they can just
try to make the Republicans so toxic
that this is okay again or figure out a
way that Commonwealth could answer that
question with some credibility I still
think Jesse the idea that they're
forgetting that there's a year away and
I mean
a lot can happen in a year we've seen
the guy falling a lot I mean it's not
getting any better years it's not it's
not four more years it's the next two
years yeah
Nikki Haley
this is a brilliant line
and here's why I spoke to a political
consultant
and he said the importance of framing
the issue is the number one thing in
politics what you want to do is you want
to frame an issue that makes your
opponent operate in a space that hurts
them so when a republican says we're
actually running against Kamala Harris
what does that make Democrats say that
makes Democrats have to talk about Joe
Biden's age Joe Biden's physical and Joe
Biden's Mental Health
it puts him in an even more awkward
position because then they also have to
insist
and acknowledge that Kamala Harris is
next in line and they have to try to say
that she's ready for the job or they
have to admit that you know what she's
not ready for the job and that makes a
point about Joe Biden that Joe Biden had
the biggest decision he'd ever make when
he names his vice president
and you're basically saying that
decision was terrible so and it also
makes black women extremely upset when
you're having a conversation about
Kamala Harris not being ready for the
job so I think not only should Nikki
Hammer this every Republican candidate
should say this we're actually running
against Kamala Harris and you just drill
it into the voters Minds you drill it
into the media's mind the Democrats mind
and make the Democrats and the media
react to that all right judge I'm going
to disagree with Jesse I think that the
decision to choose kamala's VP was
brilliant for Joe because she's so much
worse you don't pick a better choice she
was an insurance policy yeah no one's
going to go after Joe if you've got to
deal with that I know you're an idiot
Jesse Yeah but I liked it I liked what
you said I mean I liked the line that
Nikki Haley used Nikki Elias look Biden
is older than 96 of America did you know
that wow okay and yet uh when Jackie
Heinrich asked the question you know was
he going to be able to get through all
of this kjp Kareem Jean-Pierre gets all
upset and says he did things when I
think the words were he was attacked
during 2020 and he made it he showed
everyone was wrong he got elected well
that's a great reason to reelect him
again he got elected once and if
anything speaks to the issue that we
talked about in the a block and the
border and the incompetence of Kamala
Harris is the fact that she is the
borders are okay she is the woman who is
the borders are who should be protecting
how about women how about children how
about you say something that you know
I'm a woman and I'm a former prosecutor
and I want to protect these women from
being raped and I want to protect the
young girls from being molested I want
to do something no she's too busy
giggling and symbolically sitting
between Biden and McCarthy I mean give
me a break the this is this is everybody
said when Joe first ran remember he said
he was going to be a transitional
president everybody thought one of two
things one he was going to be different
than Donald Trump or he was just going
to transition so that she could be
president well they've proven their case
she can never be president because she
doesn't even know how to be vice
president she's not the borders are
she's bordering on the bazaar
and we'll be right back not before I
talk to Harold Ford with giving him the
most important question all right the
real Challenger is in Kamala because if
Joe bows out it's RFK Jr because he is
more liked than Kamala in the Democratic
party he's more liked among Independents
and obviously he's liked by Republicans
he's way more popular more sensible and
more moderate than Kamala and I secretly
think that you are closer to RFK Jr than
you are to Kamala because kamala's
radical you're not a radical RFK is a
moderate don't you think he's the real
challenge for the Republicans
you mean it because he's running against
Joe Biden yeah and Joe's not going to
make it let's say I say the odds are
Joe's not going to make it to next year
I mean as a child he's going to drop out
God for well if he would God forbid
really I just have to say something
interesting so I I think Jesse is is
right
um what com what what Nikki Haley is
saying
um puts a it's a frame and it forces
three questions and you ask him about
him about Kamala Harris and it poses the
question about RFK Jr also he's polling
20 plus percent and what it really begs
the question is do you find another
Democrat getting into the race if these
kind of questions continue to be asked I
think for Democrats to to pretend that
uh vice president Harris who was such an
accomplished attorney general whatever
you want to say about her she was she
was she was not long in the Senate but
she was a tough one crime attorney
general she got beat up by some of the
progressives on California because they
thought she was too tough around these
issues we've set it around the table if
I were her I would show up at the border
if I were her I'd show up mysteriously
in Ukraine if I were her I would lead an
effort around the country over the next
three to six months as we get ready to
go into summer we're all almost already
into summer talking about ways in which
we can help cities and municipalities
with the kinds of tools they need to
hire more police to get morale back up
and and and uh in police departments
around the country uh and to get rid of
some of this Cassius Bell and see if
it's working that's how you're going to
show people that you're ready now some
of the things they're talking about and
hiring new people all that is fine but
it's substance if we don't tackle it
that way uh I think what Jesse said and
what governor Haley's doing here uh
we'll we'll have some traction and could
couldn't end up impacting this race in
ways Democrats that we don't want it to
and you heard it here first Harold
entering the race
you heard him he said someone's coming
in we knew that I want to Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now